the stone demands a sacrifice
in order to get the stone you must give
up the thing you
love yeah no i remember
are you having difficulty deciding no no
no it's just uh
just you know i'm really thirsty you're
thirsty
okay you know what we're done here still
jesus 10 years my life
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where today i'm tossing you
a little challenge hit the subscribe
button before black widow hits the
pavement
it's called the sell your soul stone to
the algorithm of course
is this the greatest power in the
universe after a delay of almost two
whole years thanks to the pandemic
marvel's black widow solo movie is
finally in theaters and i gotta say
it is not for the kiddos don't get me
wrong as an adult thought it was totally
fine i enjoyed a lot of it but between
suffocating pigs played for laughs
non-consensual hysterectomy jokes and a
very real
undertone of child trafficking it was um
it was an intense way of hopping back
into the big screen mcu
okay it has a lot of pockets but i use
them all the time and i made some of my
own modifications
i like your best god i knew it i knew
you did it's so cool right
oh never mind screw those hundreds of
people dying in an avalanche these
brainwashed killers are so hashtag
relatable but in all seriousness i gotta
say having the mcu this huge staple of
movie going culture back in theaters
really does feel like a symbol of things
coming back into place kind of like a
page being turned on the other hand you
might be thinking well that's a nice
sentiment matpat but how much of a film
theory can you get out of black widow
when it's a two-year-old movie
and a prequel so we already know where
all this is headed to which i say
oh ye of little faith have you forgotten
that we're still finding new theories in
classics like wally heck the new shongxi
trailer revealed that the abomination is
back and we haven't seen that guy since
the incredible hulk 13 years ago
theory crafting never dies but yeah sure
we do have to work our pre-cognitive
muscles extra hard on this when
considering the main character's future
is uh
passed before it even begins and thanks
to all the release schedule shake-ups
big easter egg teaser moments like the
end credit reveal of contessa valentina
weren't such a big deal since they'd
already happened on the smaller screen
these boots are not made for walking
valentina
allegra lafontaine no my dear theorists
what i want to focus on today is
something that flew under everyone
else's radar a series of throwaway jokes
from the movie that
no one is really talking about but i
suspect might be
more than just one-liner gags in fact i
think these little quippy jokey jokey
moments might be setting up one of
marvel's deadliest and most disgusting
villains
an evil version of captain america
uh no no sorry not not that one it's a
different one
there's honestly a lot of them get ready
to pull an abomination and wait another
13 years for this one to pay off but i
think black widow
without anyone realizing it set up the
introduction of the villain you're gonna
love to hate
the disgustingly evil william burnside
i tried to make it sound intimidating
but burnside no it's not not not really
not
he's really bad also waiting 13 years
for this one to pay off hope you wound
up hitting that subscribe button earlier
i'll see you all back here in 2034 to
tell me how wrong i was anyway just to
make sure that we're all on the same
page
black widow actually takes place in
between civil war and infinity war in
the overall timeline but it focuses on
marvel's favorite metamoral of the 21st
century
found family you may have been your
father boy but he wasn't your daddy
so i am no more than another stolen
relic you're my son
i wanted only to protect you from the
truth family
back together again ah nothing says
acceptable mother figure quite like the
woman that forced you to be a sleeper
agent for mother russia in your
formative years before sending you off
to be mutilated and brainwashed against
your will into a soldier for the state
using technology that she built but
don't worry
everything is forgiven because there's
an emotional hand squeeze at the end i
don't mind that i can't birth children
anymore and that you brainwashed my
sister against her will for multiple
decades of her life it's good to see you
again mom anyway while her surrogate
mother was busy torturing pigs her
surrogate dad alexei shostakov was out
having the sort of adventures that i'm
gonna be talking about today
you see he wasn't just any former
russian spy but rather a cold war era
super soldier the soviet unions would
have been answered to captain america
the red guardian an over the hill otta
shape ultimate dad bod superhero
it still fits and while he's kind of
clueless and largely obsessed with his
own good old days he also keeps bringing
up one
story that caught my attention his fight
against captain america
god i have the nuclear code but there
he is
[Music]
i grab hold of his shield face to face
it's a test of strength anyway this
shield you know
i use it to my advantage i dig it i push
him out the window now we know
that this can't be true captain america
aka steve rogers was frozen from 1945
until the early 21st century
there was no way for him to be around at
the end of the cold war when alexei
would have been active as the red
guardian and the movie actively calls
him out on this fact
what year was this i don't know 8384
captain america was still frozen in ice
then why are you calling me a liar or
something huh so on the surface it seems
like a simple joke and a really clever
efficient bit of screenwriting to get
across what people who've never heard of
this obscure marvel character need to
know about him for the movie he was a
super soldier he has the same basic
powers as captain america and he tells
obviously fake tall tales because he's
that sort of guy
they debunk it they move on except funny
thing they keep going back to it did he
talk to you about me you know trading
more stuff oh what are you talking about
captain america my great adversary in
this
theater of geopolitical conflict okay so
there it is again which means something
else is going on by the rules of
screenwriting the captain america fight
has been set up for us in the red
guardians first scene we're then
reminded of this story at the midpoint
of the film which means that there's
gonna be some sort of payoff right like
maybe he meets captain america in some
funny way or
as part of his emotional journey he
admits that he never fought captain
america and even though everyone
already knew that it's a big deal for
him because he's been living in denial
the whole time but no
nothing ever comes of it is it maybe a
weird easter egg reference to a 1983 or
84 era comic book where the two of them
fought nope the two
do fight once in avengers number 44 but
it has nothing to do with that 80s
reference which feels oddly specific
could it be a reference to real-life
history
again not really i mean the soviet union
boycotted the 1984 summer olympics where
the russian state and 14 of its ally
nations refused to participate in the
olympic games in los angeles in response
to the us having boycotted the 1980
games in moscow but again that's
completely disconnected from anything in
the movie
so could it have just been a joke red
guardian's actor david harbour doesn't
really know
in an interview with inverse harbour
says quote i will say the stories are
absolutely true 100
part of the fun thing about alexi is
that i wasn't interested in reality
he doesn't even know that he's lying in
another interview with the rap he says
quote again i don't know like
i don't know and they won't let me tell
you even if i did know but i don't so
let's go back into mcu lore
shall we let's see if this battle could
have actually taken place based on
everything we know for those who skipped
it or those who just forgot the disney
plus series falcon of the winter soldier
told the story of how the government
gave innocent people the super soldier
serum and then tortured him to figure
out how to make the serum work for more
people
one such victim was isaiah bradley who
fought in the korean war
a handful of us got shot up with
different versions of that sorrow they
sent us on missions for the next
30 years they experimented on
me trying to figure out why the serum
worked the korean war lasted from 1950
to 1953 after the war were told that he
was imprisoned and suffered through
three decades of brutal testing before
his death was faked and isaiah was freed
under a new identity so it's unlikely
that red guardian went up against isaiah
specifically but with red guardians
saying 1983 and 1984
the timing does line up for the
government to have had other super
soldier candidates running around being
active at the same time
so to recap we have steve rogers trapped
in ice and the first round of super
soldier experiments from the 50s
completed with the test subjects all
mostly dead but what isaiah's story
tells us is that by the 80s it's highly
likely that the government had a better
version of the serum to use i mean
consider this the government had one
secret super soldier fighting in the
korean war in the form of isaiah bradley
why not have some others at later points
in history as well and it could easily
have been one of those who fought the
red guardian
the one thing that we do know about
alexi is that well he's certainly big
and kind of dumb and definitely a
braggart he's also the most
honest of black widow's team so if we
allow that he's not simply making the
whole thing up we have to allow for the
possibility that he's telling the truth
as far as he knows it he actually did
fight
not necessarily the captain america but
a captain america and this
i think is the key you see in april of
1984 there's that year again
marvel released what if number 44. what
if was a marvel anthology series
published from 1977 to 2011 which
it's basically what it said on the cover
each issue told a single self-contained
story imagining if famous events from
the marvel comics continuity had
happened differently in some way
allowing writers to try out alternate
takes on characters or just explore
ideas and concepts that fans otherwise
would never have a chance to see
it's basically the same premise as the
upcoming disney plus animated series of
the same name but
here's why it matters to red guardian's
story you see what if number 44's big
concept was
what if captain america came back today
as in what if steve rogers had stayed
frozen rather than thawing in the
mid-60s like he had in the official
marvel continuity in the comics
and the result of that what if was that
the united states would transform into a
fascist
dictatorship where all dissent is
crushed and minorities are forced to
live in racially segregated ghettos all
under the iron fist of captain america a
guy
who happens to look exactly like steve
rogers
you heard that right in what if number
44 if steve rogers stayed frozen a new
steve rogers lookalike would rise
and replace him taking on the role of
captain america and this guy
would be evil af his name william
burnside
again tried to make it sound a lot more
intimidating than it actually is it is
not that intimidating of a name what's
even weirder though is that this guy was
at one point in the comics an official
actual captain america
no what if's needed it gets a bit
confusing so follow me on this one in
the marvel comics canon
just like it is in the movies steve
rogers becomes captain america around
1941.
he fights during world war ii and he's
involved in a final mission where he
becomes frozen
only to be rediscovered in the modern
world but his story didn't always go
that way
see the original captain america world
war ii comics were actually written
during world war ii when marvel was
called timely
and american superhero comics were at
their peak popularity and originally the
story didn't end with steve meeting a
tragic fate
he just kind of kept going after the war
but without any nazis to fight
publishers struggled to find ways to
keep characters like cap relevant
at one point even trying to market the
series as a horror comic
most infamously though was when the
property jumped on the mccarthyism red
scare bandwagon of the 1950s and
rebranded steve
rogers as captain america commie smasher
it did not go over super well eventually
superheroes vanished from store shelves
for over a decade until the genre
regained popularity in the 1960s when
marvel decided they wanted to bring
captain america back in the pages of the
avengers except
they wanted to sweep all that awkward
and embarrassing post-war era cap under
the rug so they took the chance to
retcon his story by creating his new
cooler and less problematic origin story
a heroic soldier from world war
ii who bravely fought nazis before
winding up frozen in time except
turned out that not everyone forgot
about the commie smasher and those
readers demanded an answer as to what
happened to that version of captain
america marvel's answer was a bit
confusing
someone who looked just like steve
rogers who also had super soldier powers
had been
operating as captain america while steve
was a human rocket pop in captain
america number 153 marvel shocked its
readers with the story
of william burnside a scientist and
historian in the 1950s who'd grown up
obsessed with old school american
patriotism and captain america
specifically
like in a psycho stalker sense not only
did he try to develop his own bootleg
super soldier serum he got plastic
surgery and altered his vocal cords to
look and sound
just like steve rogers also he could
beat the red menace of communism and
minorities
and liberals and anyone else he deemed a
non-patriot seriously this guy is
essentially john walker from falcon in
the winter soldier cranked up to a
thousand with the same serum ramping up
his super strength also granting him the
power of super bigotry
worst power ever eventually he's
defeated by the original cap but it
leaves the real steve rogers
shaken and disturbed to know that
someone could have taken that kind of
negative lesson from him and since then
he's reappeared several times over the
years as one of marvel's most
increasingly dark and twisted bad guys
at one point becoming the grand director
which um
if the uniform didn't give it away he's
the leader of the marvel universe's kkk
anyway the story was written by steve
englehart which is also important since
the mcu has been adapting parts of his
70s and 80s work
a lot recently he wrote the original
vision in the scarlet witch miniseries
that partly inspired
wandavision he was responsible for the
epic avengers celestial madonna saga
which created a bunch of lore for kang
the conqueror and might have just ended
up inspiring somoloki
he co-created shongxi and he was also
responsible for another famous captain
america storyline called secret empire
which was the first time steve rogers
gave up the shield after becoming
disillusioned by discovering us
government corruption so
one of several stories that contributed
to falcon in the winter soldier so with
all that in mind you see where this is
going red guardian did
indeed fight captain america in the 80s
but not steve rogers
not the captain america that we know
instead he fought one of the offshoots
of the isaiah bradley research
william burnside a look-alike obsessed
with steven with a toxic
sense of patriotism the timeline of
events in the mcu work the 1984 date
lines up with that iconic what-if comic
it falls in line with marvel's current
obsession with the works of steve
englehart but most importantly it's an
interesting story that lets him continue
exploring the same theme that made steve
rogers compelling in the first place
what happens when you ask a person to
become a symbol
not a perfect soldier but a good man
so when will we see this fight actually
happen will we
ever see it happen i say yes either it's
gonna appear in the new what if series
in which case we only have a little
while to wait or
disney is waiting to see the public
reaction to red guardian and the black
widow movie to determine whether any of
those characters should continue on to
get their own series but regardless i
don't see those lines as a one-off joke
it's the sort of thing that marvel has
historically done
layer in something that they can pay off
later down the line if they want or let
it fall by the wayside so everyone
forgets about it if consumer interest
goes another way
but considering how much the internet
loved red guardian and how cool
an evil doppelganger captain america
story would be i wouldn't expect this
one to just fade away
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut
[Music]
you